* Jubel, Applaus *
Das darf man eigentlich
fast nicht sagen,
aber er ist einer meiner Favoriten
der Journalisten auf der Tour.
Er ist auch sehr gut
mit meinen Eltern befreundet.
Zudem ging er immer sehr respektvoll
mit mir und meinem Umfeld um,
auch wenn es manchmal
schwierige Dinge zu besprechen gab.
Federer ist natürlich
bis aufs Ganze gefordert.
Er will am Heimturnier,
an den Swiss Indoors in Basel,
wo alles begann,
unbedingt seinen achten Titel holen.
* Jubel *
In diesem Moment ist es so weit!
Der Turniersieger bei den Swiss
Indoors 2017 heisst Roger Federer.
Von den 9'200 Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauern im Stadion
sitzt niemand mehr.
C'est fini.
- (Kommentator) C'est fini.
Herbst 2017 - ein Jahr lang
begleiten wir Bernhard Schär.
Eben noch in Basel,
nun bereits in London
beim nächsten Tennis-Highlight.
Heute gibt's kein Siegerinterview.
Auch ein Superstar
zieht mal einen schlechten Tag ein.
Es ist nicht so einfach,
wenn man verliert.
Ich kann nicht beides.
Dann musst du
halt zuerst eine Platte abspielen,
und danach komme ich.
Ich melde mich später. Wir schauen
mal. Super, Rahel. Ciao, ciao.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass es ein Interview geben wird.
Ansonsten müssen wir das akzeptieren
und schauen,
dass wir Stimmen von der allgemeinen
Medienkonferenz verwenden können.
Es gibt sicher Möglichkeiten.
Bist du schon fertig?
- (Mann) Du musst rennen.
Seit über 20 Jahren
begleitet er mit seiner Stimme
die Karriere von Roger Federer.
Auf SRF 1 heisst er Bernhard Schär,
auf SRF 3 Berni Schär.
Mit Ausnahme der Australian Open
hat der 62-Jährige
sämtliche Grand-Slam-Titel des
Schweizer Tennisstars live miterlebt.
Seine Arbeit sei
ein grosses Privileg, findet Schär.
Respekt und Fairness zu bewahren -
unabhängig vom Resultat -
dies gehöre zum Credo
seiner journalistischen Arbeit.
(Ausser Atem) So. Hallo, Rogi.
Alles klar?
Erste Frage, Roger Federer:
Was geschah heute
gegen David Goffin?
Wie beurteilen Sie die Situation?
Ich weiss auch nicht.
Es war wie beim Armdrücken:
Irgendwann kam ich nicht mehr
richtig aus der Rücklage heraus.
Es war schade.
- Besten Dank für alles dieses Jahr.
Alles Gute.
- Danke. Ciao, ciao.
Es ist vielleicht schon so,
dass in unserer schnelllebigen
und hektischen Zeit
eher Schwarz-Weiss dominiert.
Entweder ist etwas sehr gut
oder grottenschlecht.
Ich habe immer versucht,
sauber zu bleiben, Distanz zu wahren
und die Situationen
objektiv zu beurteilen.
Dadurch bin ich auch nicht der Typ,
der jemanden schnell abschreibt,
aber auch nicht der Typ,
der übermässig lobt -
also ein Mittelmass.
Wenn der Tenniszirkus in Australien
und Übersee Halt macht,
wechselt Berni Schär auf den Schnee.
Die Lauberhornrennen
gehören fix zu seinem Jahresprogramm.
Noch einen schönen Tag.
- Mach's gut.
Auch hier setzt Berni Schär
heute auf einen Schweizer:
Ich tippe auf Sieg Feuz.
Geht ihr mit Papa Ski fahren?
- Ja.
Eine bekannte Stimme.
- Schön, dass euch das gefällt.
Das gefällt mir sehr gut.
(Mann) Hallo, Indianerfreunde.
Wie geht's?
Hallo, Freunde. Alles okay.
- Hä?
Du hast einen schönen Kopfhörer.
- Willst du einen?
Das wäre toll.
- Frag ihn, er hat auch einen.
Wie viele seid ihr? 40? 50?
- (Mann) 200.
Ah! Hedi, alles Gute für heute!
(Mann) Hedi!
- Es wird alles gut.
Das ist Beats Mutter.
Bei Tagesanbruch
ein kurzer Blick auf die Bergkulisse
und bereits steht die
erste Live-Schaltung an für SRF 3.
So, let's go!
* Handyklingeln *
Hallo, Judith.
Ich bin gerade beim Lift.
Ich steige gleich in den Lift.
Dann machen wir es vom Lift aus.
Super.
Judith, hörst du mich?
Sehr gut, sehr gut, Judith.
Je unvorhersehbarer,
umso besser für Berni.
Das wird gut, Judith.
Hört du mich noch?
Während des Fahrens
geht es nicht, oder?
So.
Okay. Dann machen wir es so.
Ich bin bereit.
Bilderbuch-Wetter, Kaiserwetter,
kann man sagen.
Man sollte die Kulisse sehen:
Eiger, Mönch und Jungfrau.
Wir trafen sogar Beat Feuz' Mutter,
Hedi Feuz, an.
Für Beat Feuz ist ein Fanklub
mit 200 Personen unterwegs.
Das muss man sich vorstellen.
Sie fuhren heute morgen
um 4 Uhr in Schangnau los
und werden
den Topfavoriten Beat Feuz
natürlich in extremis unterstützen.
Prima, Judith.
Danke schön, bis später.
Ciao, Judith, tschüss.
Topqualität, Studioqualität.
- (Mann) Ja? - Unglaublich.
Es ist authentisch.
* Hubschraubermotoren *
* Fetzige Musik im Hintergrund *
Alles Gute, Beat. Viel Glück.
Wir sahen noch deine Mutter.
Es sind 200 Fans gekommen. Sie
sind um 4 Uhr morgens losgefahren.
Hier etwas mehr in diese Richtung
und dann zum zweiten Tor.
Nach 30 Jahren kennt man einander.
Ich würde auch Interviews erhalten,
wenn ich mal nicht hinginge.
Aber für mich
gehört es seit Jahren zum Credo,
dass ich vor den Rennen
die Piste besichtige.
Einen unstillbaren Informationshunger
habe er.
Die Eindrücke auf der Piste
und von den Trainingstagen zuvor,
liefern ihm zusätzlichen Stoff
für die langen Live-Sendungen.
Die beiden
österreichischen Superstars.
Ever Salzgeber.
Alles gut, Rainer?
- Ja, und bei dir?
Ja, danke, alles tipptopp.
Und, was denkst du?
Beat Feuz.
- Beat Feuz, was?
Beat Feuz. Er sorgt für das High-
light und das grosse Fest in Wengen.
(Enthusiastisch)
Sauber rund gefahren
mit einer Ausgangsgeschwindigkeit
von 145,9 km/h.
Und jetzt rein ins Ziel-S,
wo man das Rennen nochmals gewinnen,
aber auch verlieren kann,
wo die Beine übersäuert sind.
Beat Feuz jetzt mit dem Zielsprung.
Und er ist im Ziel mit der ersten
Richtzeit von 2 Min. 26,5 Sek.
Beat Feuz, der jetzt niederkauert
und den Zuschauern winkt,
aber Beat ist erschöpft.
"Du bist echt fantastisch heute.
Mach so weiter! Hammer."
"Berni gibt 100 %. Wir sind dabei."
Das ist Motivation.
Herzliche Gratulation, Beat.
Wir machen es gleich zusammen.
Ja, super.
Jetzt folgt,
was Berni Schär am liebsten macht:
das Siegerinterview
mit einem Schweizer Sportler.
Die Bewunderung ist gegenseitig.
Er ist natürlich
eine Legende in diesem Business.
Was mich v.a. fasziniert:
Er hat nie
irgendwelche Zettel bei sich,
sondern weiss alles auswendig.
Er hat
ein extrem gutes Sportgedächtnis.
Er kennt sich ja
nicht nur im Skisport,
sondern auch im Tennis
und anderswo sehr gut aus.
Noch etwas mehr Topspin, Jonas.
Noch etwas mehr.
Von Schärs Fachkompetenz
profitiert auch Sohn Jonas -
der aktuelle U18-Schweizermeister
im Tennis.
Hopp. Und der Letzte.
Ah! Wow!
- (Mann) Break!
Wenn ich spiele ...
... ist er immer richtig streng.
So ist er immer. Aber das ist gut.
Mit ihm kommt man
richtig ins Schwitzen.
Das hilft. Das ist gut.
Perfekt, Jonas.
Ein perfekter Service. Genau so.
Ein schöner Rhythmus.
Die Tenniskarriere von Jonas
ist ein Familienprojekt.
Hast du die Teigwaren gekocht?
- Ja, die sind bereit und warm.
Die Banane habe ich dir eingepackt.
Ist das okay?
- Ja.
(Mutter) Bist du bereit?
Mmh.
Ja.
Häufiger als bei Roger Federer
verpasst Berni Schär
ein Tennisturnier seines Sohnes.
Nicht so heute:
Jonas spielt in Horgen.
Danke.
Schmeckt es?
Hast du die Halle reserviert?
(Mann per Telefon) Für morgen?
- Ja. - Nein.
Zwei berufstätige Eltern
und ein ambitionierter Sohn -
das erfordert Teamwork.
Mach's gut. Denk dran:
Beim Aufschlag ein bisschen ...
Ja, das ist okay.
Ich kenne es nicht anders.
Wir arbeiten beide unregelmässig.
Jonas so zu begleiten, kann ich
von der Arbeit her einrichten.
Berni kann natürlich nicht
immer mitkommen, das ist schade.
Aber ich geniesse es,
Jonas zu begleiten -
so lange er noch will,
dass ich mitkomme.
Ich freue mich darüber,
wie er serviert.
Er serviert wirklich gut, Ursula.
Super gespielt!
Wir erhielten
vor zwei Jahren das Angebot,
dass Jonas
nach der ordentlichen Schule
voll aufs Tennis
hätte setzen können.
Jonas wollte dies jedoch nicht.
Er wollte das Gymnasium besuchen
und die Matura machen.
Er trainiert aber
ein- bis zweimal pro Tag
und hat weiterhin
Spass am Spitzentennis.
Einer hat in Wil gewonnen.
Jonas gewinnt inzwischen
sogar internationale Turniere.
Dein Angriff ans Netz
war etwas unmotiviert.
Wenn er da ist, beobachtet er
während des Matchs sehr genau.
Danach gibt er Feedbacks
und sagt,
was ich gut
oder schlecht gemacht habe.
Dass du dich so rausgekämpft hast,
hat mich beeindruckt.
3 Uhr morgens - heute
heisst es Frühschicht in Zürich.
Ich war schon
als kleiner Junge derjenige,
der früh aufstand und für die Fa-
milie das Morgenessen vorbereitete.
Das gefiel mir auch,
als ich noch Lehrer war.
Ich bin ein Frühaufsteher.
Das liegt mir im Blut.
Ich habe noch kein einziges Mal
verschlafen - Gott sei Dank.
Das wäre mit sehr vielen
Unannehmlichkeiten verbunden.
Wir müssten
einen Pikettdienst aufbieten,
und es ist nicht sicher,
ob dieser Zeit hätte, wach wäre
und rechtzeitig
auf Sendung gehen könnte.
Bis jetzt habe ich es geschafft,
in diesen mehr als 30 Jahren
rechtzeitig im Studio zu sein.
Draussen oder im Studio - egal.
Berni Schär ist mit Feuereifer dabei
und auf den Punkt startklar.
Im Tennis bleibt Roger Federer
im deutschen Halle
weiterhin auf Erfolgskurs.
Ich habe das heute morgen gemacht,
aber auf dem Weg hierher
wusste ich natürlich schon,
was ich inhaltlich
ungefähr sagen will.
So gewinnt man Zeit.
... von Argentinien
rigoros ausgenutzt.
Wenn ich muss, bin ich total stark.
Dann mache ich keinen Fehler.
Die Antwort ist nicht drin.
- Aha.
Das wäre dann die zweite Frage.
Du improvisiert bei den Antworten?
- Freestyle.
Mmh.
Und dann achtest du
ein wenig auf die Länge.
Ja.
- Okay?
Als ich vor 30 Jahren
in diesem Gebäude anfing,
arbeitete man noch mit dem Telex.
Man riss die Meldungen ab,
hängte sie an der Wand auf
und fasste sie
anschliessend zusammen.
Heute geschieht dies
alles elektronisch.
Hinzu kommen
die Social-Media-Reaktionen,
es sind mehr Leute involviert.
Es ist unterhaltsamer,
komplexer, aber interessanter.
So dass ich
gegen Ende meiner Tätigkeit bei SRF
noch einmal richtig gefordert bin.
(Moderator) Amy Sharks neues Album
erscheint Mitte Juli.
Mit dem Song des Tages
hören wir sie auf SRF 3 nochmals.
Für Fabian Unteregger,
der Berni parodiert,
hat er schon fast Kultstatus.
Vorbildlich.
Schau mal, meine Schrift!
Boah!
- Mach das Ding zu.
Fährst du wieder nach Wimbledon?
- Ja.
Hängt dir das
nicht langsam zum Hals raus?
Im Gegenteil. Ich fahre
dieses Jahr zum 20. Mal hin.
Ich begann 1998 mit Martina Hingis.
- Echt? Nein!
Ja. Das ist doch gut.
- Unglaublich.
Und jetzt
wieder die Nummer 1 der Welt.
Federer ist gesetzt. Fantastisch.
Achtung, Berni!
Berni fällt
von der ersten Sekunde an auf,
an der man ihn am Radio hört.
Obwohl man ihn nicht sieht,
kommt er mit einem ganzen Paket
an Energie über den Äther.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Teil
der DNA von Berni Schär am Radio.
Kroatien zerzaust
und deklassiert Argentinien -
nämlich gleich mit 3:0 -
und zeigt eine starke Teamleistung
und harten Einsatz
in den Zweikämpfen.
Es gibt
so gewisse Regeln im Radio
und dann gibt es
auch immer Berni Schär.
Meistens hält er diese Regeln
schon auch ein,
aber er ist halt einfach spontan
und dann diese Leidenschaft ...
Man muss einfach bereit sein.
Es kommt aber immer gut,
und das ist da das Tolle daran:
Es ist lebendig,
wenn Berni hier im Studio ist.
Und Länge ist meistens ein Problem?
An der Länge arbeiten wir noch.
Aber das sage ich
schon seit zehn Jahren.
Berni im Glück.
An keinem anderen Tennisanlass
blüht der 62-Jährige
so auf wie in Wimbledon.
Dies nicht nur, weil Roger Federer
hier bereits achtmal gewonnen hat.
Man weiss, was einen
hier in Wimbledon erwartet.
Ich habe seit 20 Jahren die gleiche
Position auf dem Center Court.
Die Ruhe und Gelassenheit, die
die Anlage ausstrahlt, blieb gleich.
V.a. Attribute wie Anstand,
Fairplay und Respekt
gegenüber anderen dominieren.
Das sind eigentlich auch die Werte,
die Roger Federer in der weiten Welt
des Tennis verkörpert.
Das ist letztlich auch der Grund,
warum er immer wieder
gerne hierherkommt
und Wimbledon als sein absolutes
Lieblingsturnier bezeichnet.
Ich habe dich gesucht.
- Ich bin gerade gekommen.
In den Jahren sind auch
viele Freundschaften entstanden,
wie die zu Robert Federer.
Vielleicht spielt er ja hier.
Das glaube ich nicht.
- Nein?
Letztes Jahr war er viel hier.
Roger spielt dort hinten
oder dort unten. - Möglich.
Gell, gestern war anfangs
zum ersten Mal sein Sohn dabei.
Ja, ich war überrascht.
Aber er sagte mir,
dass unter Fünfjährige nicht während
des ganzen Matchs erlaubt sind.
Darum nahm er ihn danach raus
und brachte ihn am Ende wieder rein.
Ah, okay.
Das ist in Wimbledon klar geregelt.
Unter Fünfjährige
dürfen keinen ganzen Match sehen.
Die kennst du nicht?
- Ich kannte sie nicht.
Aber du weisst doch alles, Berni.
Aber ich sage dir eins:
Ich habe bei ihm super recherchiert.
Schau, dort geht Roger.
Ja, Berni ...
Er ist sehr
mit den Federers verbunden.
Er hat Rogis Vertrauen, er
hatte es bereits in jungen Jahren.
Wir treffen ihn
an allen Grand Slams.
Es ist einfach toll,
mit ihm zusammen zu sein.
Wir treffen uns regelmässig
auch eine halbe Stunde bis 1 Std.
vor den Matches.
Sein Sohn spielt ja auch gut Tennis.
So redeten wir
auch immer ein wenig darüber.
Manchmal mussten wir ihm
ein wenig zureden,
Jonas etwas mehr Freiheiten
zu lassen
und nicht das Gefühl zu haben,
ihn dauernd beschützen zu müssen.
Wir haben immer gute Gespräche.
Dies bietet sich
v.a. auch an den Tagen an,
wenn auf der Anlage trainiert wird.
Bringst du mir Tennisbälle?
- Tennisbälle?
Ja. Hallo, Rogi.
Alte?
- Alte und neue.
Bis später, oder?
- Ja, ja.
Hast du noch etwas von Nadal gehört?
Er ist hier.
- Ach, ja?
Als Nummer 2 gesetzt.
Ich glaube,
er trainierte viel in Mallorca.
Genau wie Roger Federer
ist auch Berni Schär
im Herbst seiner Karriere.
Spätestens in zwei Jahren
soll Schluss sein.
Dies weiss man auch
im Umfeld von Roger Federer.
I always enjoy talking to you.
Congratulations on
your success in life,
on the tennis court
and on the radio.
Thank you very much, Tony Godsick.
Toll!
You're pretty good.
- It was funny too. Thank you.
Thank you for it.
- Thank you very much. - Perfect.
Hi, Roger, Gratulation!
- Wie geht's?
Ich musste gerade Tony Godsick
ein Interview geben.
Oh, nein!
- Zuerst über dich ...
Das tut mir aber leid für dich.
- ... und über meine Tenniskünste.
Es war so lustig.
Roger Federer,
zwei Matches sind gespielt.
Man kann sagen,
Sie sind 2018 in Wimbledon dabei?
Ja, ich bin zufrieden,
dass ich es geschafft habe.
Irgendwie hing eine Wolke
über diesem Match.
Das ist doch wunderbar.
Er möchte danach gerne
der nächsten Generation
von Radio-Superstars helfen.
Ich sagte zu ihm: "Das ist
genau das, was du tun solltest."
"Aber bitte nimm dir
auch Zeit für das Leben,
für dich, für die Familie."
Das kam sicher
auch ab und zu zu kurz.
Er darf
auch von zu Hause aus arbeiten.
Ich denke, die nächsten zwei Jahre
werden die Besten
seiner Karriere sein.
Ich versuche, so lange zu spielen,
aber ich kann die ganze Situation
nicht mit Berni Schär verankern.
Wie steht es jetzt?
Ähm, ich glaube, 6:0 und 1:0.
- 6:0 und 1:0.
Bernhard Berni Schär hat mit seiner
Stimme das Schweizer Tennis geprägt.
Für die Radiolegende wird
der Tennissport Mittelpunkt bleiben
in seinem Leben,
aber ganz im Kreis der Familie:
mit Ehefrau Ursula und Sohn Jonas.
Man muss gut variieren,
weil er sehr schnell ist.
Sehr beweglich.
Das gefällt mir eigentlich an ihm.
Ich freue mich,
wenn er mehr zu Hause
und nicht mehr so oft weg ist.
Das wird sicher eine
schöne Zeit für die ganze Familie,
auch für meine Mutter.
Dann werden wir wieder
mehr gemeinsame Zeiten haben
und können vielleicht wieder mal
gemeinsam in die Ferien fahren.
Im Moment hat er zu einem
anderen Zeitpunkt Ferien als ich.
Darauf freue ich mich sehr.
Dass wir wirklich
mehr Zeit füreinander haben.
Dass wir weniger
in Stresssituationen
planen und entscheiden müssen,
wer was macht.
Dass wir eine weniger stressige Zeit
haben, in Ruhe.
Einmal begleitet er Jonas, einmal
ich oder wir machen es gemeinsam.
Einfach wieder mehr Zeit
zu dritt als Familie unterwegs sein.
Gratulation.
Du hast genau so gespielt,
wie du gegen einen solchen Spieler
spielen musst. - Wie?
Dein Spiel durchziehen und nicht
plötzlich unkonventionell spielen.
Das war sehr gut.